attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
3 2 1 à la base deux week-ends tu fais
mon n'a pas fini moi je vais pas
commencer c'est ça ma technique je vous
font rien de la matinée comme ça ça
bloque pas la pause déj bon j'ai entendu
que ma cote de popularité avait baissé
dans l'entreprise en conséquence de quoi
pour me faire bien voir
je déjeune avec vous je vais chercher un
kebab 120 la viande trop cuit excuser
les paramètres qui se grattent le cul
non non je vais prendre une pizza plutôt
[Musique]
si loin ouais tu peux mettre acteurs
castellet le maté aussi que peuvent tout
spoil respect ouais ça m'excite
qu'est ce tu manges nadine salaires des
violences brocoli pattes et un fonds de
couscous je récupère tout ce que mes
enfants mangent pas puis je me fais une
gamelle et c'est bon non c'est la merde
c'est pas avec les 4 euros 50 de tickets
resto que je peux aller manger dehors
tous les midis j'entends autre remarque
nadine je ne vais rien changer mais
c'est noté les [ __ ] s'étonner c'est
pour qui la margarita froide
ouais c'est pour moi qu'est-ce qui
s'aimait si ça fait trois plans que
j'attends je déraille avec le vélo plus
fine chaussée humide je me suis éclaté
contre un pare brise du coup c'est plus
une margarita mais une pizza calzones et
en mai juin 12 95
non c'est pas un épisode de motus je
cherche pas la boule noire c'est juste
que c'est cette gagner du temps qu'on
samedi doazit garde la monnaie équipe
non j'ai tout le temps
et ce midi les cafés c'est pour moi ça
me fait plaisir c'est gentil ça ah non
c'est pas gentil
non il ya un conte qui a oublié sa
monnaie la machine à café 1 3 euros en
petites pièces au nom c'était vrai ça eh
ben ça a tourné lundi dès lors pour moi
capuccina aulas rita l'os windows
[Musique]